since his 1978 debut Michael Myers has
remained one of the original slasher
movie mascots after all he's already
survived multiple decades worth of
evolution retcons and reinventions
it's hard to believe that an evil force
of nature like Michael Myers could
actually exist based on the way Dr
Loomis talks about him throughout the
series Myers seems more like an ancient
figure from folklore than an actual
human being however director John
Carpenter credits the creation of
Michael Myers to a school trip where he
and his peers visited a mental Asylum
Carpenter discussed this fateful trip in
the documentary A Cut Above the Rest
saying we visited the most serious
mentally ill patients and there was this
kid he must have been 12 or 13 and he
literally had this look that image stuck
with Carpenter who Incorporated the idea
into the original Halloween film in
which a young Michael Myers stares into
the camera unmasked having committed a
heinous crime it's fairly common
knowledge that Michael Myers iconic mask
was actually an augmented William
Shatner mask in fact the script
contained no description of what Michael
Myers mask should actually look like
while on a panel at the Fright Night
Film Fest and horror weekend August 2008
filmmaker Tommy Lee Wallace who worked
behind the scenes on the original
Halloween explained the script asked for
a blank faced mask that makes you feel
eerie the killer was also never referred
to as Michael Myers and instead was
simply called the shape with no Specific
Instructions Wallace went to a costume
shop on Hollywood Boulevard looking for
the perfect mask he selected The Faded
William Shatner mask choosing the Emmett
Kelly clown character weary Willy is a
backup while they ultimately picked the
shatter mask young Michael does wear a
clown mask when murdering his sister
Wallace would later bring an eerie clown
to the screen when he directed the 1990
TV adaptation of Stephen King's It
since Michael Myers is just a guy in a
mask almost anyone could play the part
John Carpenter's longtime friend Nick
Castle is credited as the shape in the
first film but he wasn't the only actor
to play the role in 1978's Halloween
during the movie's opening a young actor
named will sandin plays a six-year-old
Michael who brutally murders his older
sister we see his face when the clown
mask is ripped away for a shocking
reveal during the climax of the film
Michael's mask is torn off again and
this time he's played by actor Tony
Moran however they weren't the only
actors responsible for bringing one of
Cinema's greatest Boogeyman to life in
the original movie in fact producer and
co-writer Deborah Hill had to step in to
play the role of six-year-old Michael's
hands the point of view sequence was so
complicated that filmmakers were unable
to bring in another child to be
Michael's heads in Adam rockoff's book
going to Pieces the rise and fall of the
slasher film 1978-19 6 Hill explained we
couldn't afford another kid to hold the
knife later that night so that's my hand
holding the knife that stabs Michael
Myers sister I had the littlest tense
the antagonist took a relationship
between Dr Loomis and Michael Myers
provides the Mythic undertones of the
Halloween series Loomis is determined to
end Michael's reign of evil especially
as it was Loomis who tried to treat
Michael following the original murder
basically no one knows Michael better
than Loomis if you don't find him in
four hours
I'm sure I will that connection runs
even deeper when you realize that the
actor who played Loomis Donald Pleasence
worked with stuntman dick warlock who
portrayed Michael in the original
Halloween 2 on The 1975 Disney film
Escape to Witch Mountain discussing his
time working with Pleasants warlock told
Halloween Daily News I found him to be a
gentleman people have said that he had a
sense of humor but I never saw it when
he came on set he was ready to work he
knew your dialogue and mine he was the
consummate professional you couldn't
find anybody who was better to work with
Halloween 3 season of the witch is
usually referred to as the Halloween
movie without Michael Myers on the
surface this is a totally fair statement
while Halloween and Halloween 2 are one
continuous story detailing the night
Michael Myers came home the third
installment was intended to take the
franchise in a totally different
direction in the documentary Standalone
the making of Halloween 3 season of The
Witch director Tommy Lee Wallace
explained the decision to create an
anthology movie saying each year let's
come out with a new movie on the subject
of Halloween All Hallows Eve and
everything that comes with it it could
go in any direction at once and each one
could spin off any number of their own
sequels and I don't know what the hell
is going on at the time the film wasn't
a hit with moviegoers and everyone's
favorite masked killer was brought back
in Halloween for the return of Michael
Myers still it could be said that Mars
presence is felt throughout the movie as
dick warlock who played Michael
Halloween 2 appears in a new role plus a
TV spot for the original 1978 film
featuring Michael Myers is shown on
television in Halloween 3. he may not be
the huge presence audiences were hoping
for but he still made it into the film
one of the few actors to play Michael
Myers more than once is George P Wilbur
who portrayed the shape in Halloween for
the return of Michael Myers and
Halloween the curse of Michael Myers
interestingly the stuntman credits John
Wayne with his career in Show Business
after serving in the Navy Wilbur got a
job at a Dude Ranch in Tucson telling
racks and razors they were filming the
movie El Dorado nearby so I went to the
set and got a job as an extra and a
stand-in for John Wayne shortly
afterward I moved to Los Angeles to
pursue a career as a stuntmen that
career certainly paid off as he went on
to add over 100 credits to his name and
got to play the shape on two separate
occasions Halloween 5 the Revenge of
Michael Myers is a flawed film to say
the least while the fourth installment
did an excellent job of bringing the
franchise back to basics part 5 took the
series into surreal territory one of the
movie's more bizarre Concepts depicts a
mysterious Men In Black with the same
tattoo as Michael roaming around
Haddonfield and breaking Michael out of
prison in the sixth film The Man in
Black was revealed to be Dr Terence Wynn
a character with only one scene in the
original Halloween I protect Michael
however that wasn't always the intention
in fact Don Shanks who played Michael in
the fifth film revealed that the movie's
director originally had different plans
for the character as Shanks told
Halloween Daily News I was going to be
the man in Black because I played him
too I did bits and pieces I didn't do
all of him but there would be scenes
where I'd go out one door here and I
just put on the coat and come through
the other door however this idea doesn't
make a lot of sense which is probably
why it was dropped as underwhelming as
the Dr Win reveal was having Michael be
the man in Black would have just been
plain confusing
in 1998 Halloween H2O 20 years later
came out rebooting the franchise and
creating a brand new timeline in the
process the idea to continue Laurie
strode's story two decades on actually
came from Jamie Lee Curtis herself as
she told Entertainment Weekly in 2018
when Halloween was like 19 years old I
remember calling John Carpenter and
Deborah Hill and we had lunch I said to
them guys the movie is going to be 20
years old next year and we're all still
doing the job 20 years later I said to
them why don't we revisit it Halloween
H2O ignored everything that took place
after Halloween 2 and it was supposed to
depict Lori taking down Michael Myers
once and for all as the project
continued however Curtis started reading
scripts that left Michael's demise more
ambiguous that's when she learned that
producer Mustafa alakad who had control
over the character included a clause in
the contract that said Michael Myers
cannot be killed a compromise made and a
new ending was produced in which Lori
appears to chop Michael's head off the
idea was it would make the audience feel
like Michael is finally officially dead
but it could also easily be explained
away in a sequel indeed its successor
Halloween resurrection revealed that
Laurie had actually killed a man that
Michael had dressed in his clothes
allowing the murderer to escape sadly
the audience of Halloween H2O was robbed
of a truly satisfying ending oh my God
she killed the wrong person when the
time came to officially reboot the
Halloween franchise in 2007 Rob Zombie
was brought in to remake the original
film in his own Vision he decided his
Michael Myers should be the most
visually intimidating Michael to date so
he cast the six foot nine inch actor and
former professional wrestler Tyler Maine
although his face is obscured throughout
most of the film some viewers recognized
him as Sabretooth from 2000's X-Men
zombies 2007 remake of Halloween and its
2009 follow-up are much darker and more
brutal than the original aside from a
handful of scary moments a young person
could watch John Carpenter's Halloween
and walkway relatively unscathed zombies
reboot however is incredibly violent and
crude so much so that even the child
actor playing a young Michael Myers in
the movie wasn't allowed to read the
entire script during an interview with
MovieWeb to promote the film actor Jake
Ferrick explained I only read my part
and then my mom read it and then she
said you're not gonna read that and once
the film was finished ferric still
wasn't allowed to see it the young actor
revealed that he would be allowed to
watch the beginning of the film but
would have to leave the premiere and go
do something else after that on account
of zombies flick being too gruesome I am
going to be kept away even for the
premiere I'm gonna watch maybe the first
10 15 minutes given the film's onslaught
of profanity grotesque violence and
grisly murders it's easy to see why
fairc wasn't allowed to watch the entire
movie despite playing such a major role
2018's Halloween which was directed by
David Gordon green gloriously rebooted
the franchise by largely ignoring all of
its sequels even Halloween 2 the
filmmakers worked hard to honor the
original 1978 film by bringing back
Jamie Lee Curtis and enlisting John
Carpenter to score the new movie in
another important nod for hardcore fans
Nick Castle was also brought back to
occasionally embody the role of Michael
Myers which he helped originate although
Castle didn't play the character for any
large stretch of time in 2018's
Halloween fans loved his inclusion in
the movie although Castle wasn't on set
for the filming of Halloween kills his
voice or should we say breath was used
extensively as James Jude Courtney the
actor and stuntman who portrays Michael
Myers in Green's Trilogy told Halloween
Daily News so when I'm stalking you and
you hear the breathing in The Mask it's
Nick Castle breathing which I think
again is very poetic because Nick is the
spirit of this character it's Nick's
spirit that I reached in and grabbed
manifest the 2018 character
[Music]